oh hi thank you for joining me on a to
Canada pride thank you for having I
can't believe this is your first time on
a t Canada I know yes you know invited
me earlier well I'll invite you all the
time as often as you want to come back
good yeah well I have to say
congratulations on everything you have
built such a strong career and I know
making videos and creating is something
that you want it to do from a very young
age how does it feel to have actually
done it to be where you are right it's
definitely crazy
there are times where I didn't like to
used to it and then I like have a moment
where I'm like I'm exactly where I
dreamed of being when I was like 15 and
like 14 you know and I've always been
making videos ever since I was like 8
and I watched each I was growing up I
wanted to be at all the conventions and
now some of these people that I looked
up to you're like my closest friends so
it's absolutely crazy
it must be crazy because like this is
something that I dreamed of in my life
yeah and it's just like that thought
that something you dream of can actually
come to fruition and happen mm-hmm it's
insane yeah it doesn't feel real a lot
of the time I feel like I'm in a dream
right now I'm like what am i doing I
want to say like what have it yeah it's
super cool you're going to buffer
festival this weekend super exciting
it's not your first time going oh this
is um my third fourth buffer fourth but
Wow yeah what do you love about the
festival I love how this is like one of
the only festivals and conventions out
in terms of YouTube that focuses on the
content yeah and it's about creativity
and celebrating the content over the
Creator and I really enjoy that it's a
nice it's like a breath of fresh air
yeah in this YouTube world so yeah for
sure who are their friends that you'll
see this weekend that you're looking
forward to seeing I've seen a lot of
them because a lot of my British friends
come over okay so this is always a fun
event to see them at is it weird for you
to think of yourself as a celebrity or a
role model yeah I don't really see
myself that way at all
yeah cuz I live like I bet my life is
pretty much the same from before YouTube
when I'm home but well outside of that
it is very different obviously if I want
to come back home it's like seeing my
high school friends seeing my family
then picking on me
same old same old I told you before we
came out here that I kind of found fell
down the rabbit hole of your videos this
week in my office and I love them you
are real you talk about important things
and I appreciate that so much
but something that struck me this is et
Canada pride was your coming-out video
yes
that was incredible GDQ was community
[Music]
different I'm animals and I'm sure tell
me about why you felt the need to come
out at that time I feel like the months
leading up to it it was really taking a
toll on me um I was I became really shut
down and I was pushing people away and I
wasn't gonna real weight on my shoulders
and I feel like I finally got to the
point where no is it inner battle I was
like I don't know what's going on I'm
very confusing them ice I brought into
the YouTube world and back in my
hometown it wasn't really talked about
and so I was finally exposed to people
where it was a norm you know and I was
able to talk about it and figure out my
feelings and once I finally accepted it
I was ready to tell the world and I kind
of wanted to do it all one go inside
made a video I noticed I love the way
you wrapped the house and my side colors
like and your mom's reaction it was just
so sweet the reaction from fans to like
I was going through comments like to
have that reception to that coming out
how did that feel for you because it was
probably just a giant weight off your
shoulders
Oh hundred percent at first it was
really nerve-racking I remember that day
my face was just super high and like I
couldn't focus on anything else but
everyone was so accepting and so so so
sweet like I was expecting a lot of
support but just the to the extent of it
what it was it
I couldn't have imagined that yeah what
I love too is just seeing how you
through your own Pride Parade
that is super cool I think more people
should do that because not everywhere
has their own pride yeah absolutely
tell me about having all those people
come out to celebrate it was insane
because it was really last minute and I
remember when I saw in person I was like
wow this is sick like cuz I'm like in
usually even videos it looks better on
camera but like in person I was like
blown away I chose was like there's so
many people here everyone's super
excited and like it was like an hour of
us just screaming and like being proud
of who we are and like it was a lot of
fun for sure are you gonna come down or
try to come down to Toronto Pride I'm
hoping yes I really need to I've been
wanting to for so long I always get
asked but sometimes I feel like most of
time it's like work gets in the way yeah
there's a conversation that still goes
on that really irritates me and gets
under my skin and it's like bisexuality
isn't a thing yeah you know and I don't
know why people have that mentality
still because I know plenty of people
who are bisexual yeah have you have had
any backlash from when you came out
I'd say backlash is in the word there's
definitely people who probably they
doubt it they're like I think you're
just gay or so on and that's actually
more people in my real life yeah I also
don't really look too much into the
comments so like but yeah I do get that
in real life a lot and it's tough it's
just I feel like I don't think it to you
personally I just feel like they're just
uneducated and maybe like just a bit
ignorant maybe and me I don't think
sometimes that's just from their
upbringing but the best we can do is
just like talk about yeah exactly
be like this is how I feel this is my
truth and hopefully you believe it I
don't know it's it's tough it is yeah
and I mean what can you do you know you
can't force people to change their mind
on something but all you can do is try
to educate people exactly you have a
huge fan base like millions of
subscribers when you're meeting the
fans what kind of messages are they
sharing with you a lot of them are very
sweet you know someone's just a lot of
them are always really excited and they
say that you know watching that my
videos makes them really happy like it's
a little bit of an escape a lot of them
do you say talk about my coming-out
video and it's helped them come out I
get that a lot and that's always super
super touching you know that my
coming-out experience was able to help
them move forward in their coming-out
experience and I have had a lot of
mental health videos and so there's
always a lot of talking about that and
that's really is you know what I mean
because like you keep it real you know
you share with your fans that you are
having mental health issues and how
you're dealing with those issues
YouTube burnout I think is is that the
phrase that is the phrase it's yeah yeah
I mean YouTube burnout is essentially
just a mental health you need a break
then just take care of yourself so how
are you doing now with the mental health
and finding time to take care of
yourself
you like in comparison where I was it's
early 2018 a lot better okay um I
definitely think because I have such
great people around me of my management
my agent um my friends and family
they're able to you know help me say no
to things as well.these I have a huge
problem with saying no and they're able
to help me prioritize and you know
figure out what I could handle and if
something's too much they're able to say
no you can't do this and we're able to
meet an imbalance if you're currently
struggling with your mental health I
highly encourage you to reach out to
someone such as a family member a friend
or professional what is the feeling that
you get when you post a video do you
still cuz like when I post a new pride
episode I'm sometimes get like oh my
gosh so people are gonna watch this what
is it do you still get those I Fisher
get those we do add my upper schedule
because of the burnout has like
decreased and so I get really nervous
I'm like are people still gonna care I'm
still gonna watch and I've been very
fortunate that people are still stucked
around and are still excited
my content and I put a lot of effort
into them so it's always nerve-racking
like is this good enough what people
like it but yeah usually after a day I'm
like you know it's all right people
enjoy it we're good or chillin and I'm
able to be fantastic why is it so
important for you to be ia open book to
your fans I don't know it's it is on
because I feel like growing up I've
never been an open book and I just feel
like my videos are very much little
snippets stories from my life and so I
don't think much of like holding back I
guess I don't care what people think as
long as the story is told I feel like in
a right way I'm a truthful way I think
what it is for me is my number one
priority is genuine genuine genuine
that's really like super important to me
and I feel like you just have to be
completely honest sometimes brutally
honest you know what do you still want
to achieve I know you have a merch line
right now which I was just saying a
supercool the logos and everything is
great thank you yes unlike my cousin he
does all my channel or thumbnails he he
designs all the merch so yeah I'm really
proud of it I think he does a great job
with that and I always like he's always
been into art ever since he was a kid
and so I love to like help him like push
them in the direction to help him with
that yeah I didn't do much bigs plan -
oh yeah I just did I just hosted a
series with cut channel cut they have a
great channel on Facebook
it's called kids playing and I basically
help kids plan a day for the parents
what else do you want to achieve because
not like I'm not trying to minimize but
you are still very young you have
achieved a lot so far so what do you
still dream up to it I I definitely want
you to rest
I feel like definitely I've been on sets
I've been seeing us a lot of other
people's projects so I could to get
experience on set and like shadowing
people directly I want to write my own
like movie I love to write a team movie
and direct it and so that's the ultimate
dream and that's definitely what I'm
working towards
and I'm just kind of kicking a little
baby steps all the way there they're
taking my time yeah there's no rush yeah
what you got time exactly don't rush I'm
what message would L send to people who
may be unsure about their sexuality
maybe unsure of who they are
what do you send to them from your own
experience I feel like first of all you
don't owe anyone anything
your coming-out experiences for you and
so do y'all I feel like don't feel
obligated to like have to label yourself
or you know feel like you had to tell
every single person in your life that's
all it's totally up to you also take
your time
yeah like you know just like there's no
rush yeah you know and yeah just like I
think those are the two things I feel
like there's I feel like that's the
thing I was feeling when I'm doing my
coming-out experience was like its
pressure to figure out what it is
because I was just like I was so
confused but like I feel like I could
have just like you know taking a
day-by-day there was no rush at all like
and yeah I feel like that's the one
piece of us I wish I wish I would have
got him yeah that's very smart advice
this was super fun and I want you to
come back all the time all right cool
well thank you for joining us thank you
so much every good
[Music]